well thank you thank you so much
good morning and thank you again
professor on for you your Dean and my
friend congratulation to you Peter on
your achievement at the Dean of general
city for so many years and thank you for
inviting me and for that glowing and
traduction Thank You president Bollinger
vice president Dirk and Kurtis Roger
coordinated my visit I'm more than
delighted I'm unable to believe that I'm
here in for review today but especially
congratulations to all of you graduate
this is an extraordinary achievement and
I'm really honored to share this day
with you when I graduated from General
City on June 2 1970 the Dean of general
sorry what Aaron Warner I would never
have thought that 40 years or so later I
would be here giving the commencement
address this is a surprise and a great
honor I'm here today as your speaker to
inspire you I'm not sure that I can do
it but I will try I came to the United
State on a student boat traveling from
Louisville in France to Quebec City and
then one I went on by train from Quebec
to New York City Grand Central Station
it was 1959 I was 23 years old I'd left
my country and came here as an immigrant
ready to conquer the world I was already
a chef at the time we've been work for
10 years in some of France best
restaurant in Paris and in my family
restaurant around Lyon and to all of
those years I had remained a chef on
that ship in the fall of 1959 they were
1,200 American student coming back from
summer vacation and study in Europe and
it took 10 days to sell from North
America I befriended a free student on
the ship but it was difficult could I
spoke very little English at the time
nevertheless I spoke I met a man who
spoke enough French so that we could
converse and I asked him what the best
school in New York was without
hesitation he said Columbia University
I arrived in New York on the 10th of
September began working at a famous
French restaurant called a pavilion on
the 12th and then roll the following
week here to study English for foreign
student I had to learn how to study
again because I had left school at 13
after primary school to begin my cooking
apprenticeship from September of 59
until July 1972 I study every term at
Columbia and except for my final two
years when I was in the Graduate School
of art and science spent most of that
time in general study after the
non-credit English language study I went
into a validation program and eventually
will accept it in the regular Bachelor
of the great program and ultimately
completed Graduate Studies
it took years and it was the greatest
time of my life I'm still amazed at my
luck in my mid-20s with only a primary
school education to be accepted at
Columbia University was nothing short of
miraculous
I believe it could not have happened in
any other country and it could not have
happen in any other schools and general
study I certainly want to thank some of
my many professor at the time in general
sorry for those years to give their
knowledge and their passion and to
tutored me and advised me by thank to
Professor Cheatham a professor fellow
professor Edelman professor frame
professor sorry professor Riveter among
many others I believe I did well in most
of my subject except maybe in phonetics
as you can clearly hear so general study
had and still have the greatest attea
national student body at least 25
percent you had to be motivated to study
here most people pay for the study as I
did about the typical non-traditional
student an owl which represented the
night student in general study most of
my fellow classmate had pursued their
education for years had no college
background or like me never even had a
secondary education most could only
study part-time because of work family
commitment or military duty at this time
in general sorry the English class
foreign student were attended by a fair
amount of people from Spanish Asian and
Eastern European bloc country the
student body was vibrant on to the astok
curious and demanding in many ways there
was no age limit no class system no sham
of a lowly background or lack of
education I remember walking the
university campus over and over it
became my hangout to think a place of
meditation a place for meeting with
friend or just looking at life going by
it was my comfort zone long before I
came somewhat articulate in English in
America we are lucky to have the
possibility of an education at any age
without being penalized looped down lost
art or ridiculed there is no limit if
you have ambition like many of you I pay
for my education by working during the
day and studying at night I like the
restaurant business world but I had
somewhat of a complex about not having
much of a formal education I wanted a
dreamed of becoming educated or teaching
or writing I also remember amazing
discussion at the cafeteria across
campus on Broadway with five six eight
classmates from different part of the
world all with bad English all full of
hope all excited and happy to be in
America where everything was possible to
us truly America and I had a vision it I
eventually moved into the graduate
school with my heart and youthful
excitement remain a general study during
the year that I took class there the
debate with my fellow student on subject
ranging from politics to art we are good
at for improving our English the
students were engaged and it was
exhilarating we shared an invigorating
feeling that I've never found again and
I proceeded with my education elsewhere
but it turned out my professional life
did not judgments throughout the
following years but it was considerably
enhanced by my liberal arts study I was
still a chef but a different level than
before I started writing articles books
and eventually worked on television none
of this would have happened if I had not
gone to jail
I'll study my life was totally change
and bettered because of those years of
studies at almost 75 years of age I am
still a chef
and also the chef had climbed up the
social ladder at that time it was
considered a relatively lowly and
uninspired job getting an education
preventing me from having a complex
about not having an education
I was now a proud college graduate and
the job I was doing I did it by choice
because I wanted to and I felt good
about about myself because of my
education at the school of general study
sky was the limit today you have your
degree and it is the beginning of your
career the beginning of your life it is
a time of hope a time to believe in
yourself a time to dare it is a time
when the world impossible does not exist
in your vocabulary a time to reach for
the sky remember that you are the want
to create opportunities for yourself in
life you're responsible for your
happiness
have the courage to try fortune smiles
on the audacious you have a long road in
front of you but it is a good road a
happy road on this special day the world
is yours world and the future is your
future to shape the degree that you are
getting today it with you for the rest
of your life it is a testament to your
accomplishment it is much more than a
certificate and it will remain in your
mind and in your heart forever the
knowledge that you have acquired here is
a knowledge that you would passed on to
your children and your children's
children because the education that you
have completed the general theory is
unique however with that recognition
come also responsibility responsibility
is to become engaged in society to
change things for the better and to
leave a mark
time time to reflect on your life in the
last few years take time to enjoy your
life now life itself is the reward the
benchmark the recompense sometimes we
are so intent in looking forward that we
forget the present moment don't make
that mistake
look forward runs over here and now then
in time of hardship when life become
difficult but it usually dull at some
point think of this moment no one can
take this woman away from you this is
yours and yours alone an accomplishment
to be proud of an achievement that will
convert you in darker days remember that
success in life is very simple and very
complex success in life is to be happy
with yourself with what you are with
what you do if you love what you do you
know you never have to go to work money
for the sake of money doesn't make a
person happy although it may contribute
to a fair amount don't forget the simple
pleasure of life for me it is still a
sharing a meal or a bottle of wine with
friend the enjoyment of being together
with family in front to share this is
true happiness I've been blessed with a
wonderful wife for over 43 years a great
daughter and a carrier that I have
enjoyed for more than 60 years again the
greatest advice I can give you is to do
what you love I've been asked as a chef
how does your general degree you general
study degree help where does it fit into
your life I firmly believe that without
it I would never have had the carrier as
complete and as successful as I did the
story of liberal art literature
philosophy open your mind and it makes
me a more complete person that I would
be otherwise I would have been a
complete without it as a graduate of
general study you are important your
education enables you to offer us to
affect and to touch the people around
you from your family to your frown and
beyond I believe in the goodness of
human nature with some people and at
some time it does seem not to be too
apparent but the goodness is there with
some digging it appears and it is well
worth the effort to reveal it don't
forget that now with your education you
can analyze you can understand you can
be open tolerant this is what a liberal
education does for you with the
education that I got here at gs I can
truly say that the sky has been the
limit
an education is important to quote
Gilbert Chestertown an English writer of
the last century without an education
you're in the honourable and deadly
danger of taking educated people
seriously this should not happen to you
you know you should be able to reflect
on your life and laugh at yourself
occasionally don't take yourself too
seriously
finally I want to thank you for the
wonderful honour of addressing you today
I wish I could start my study right here
all over again congratulation and have a
great life